what kind of negative effects are we
looking out for like what what are the
properties of drugs we should be careful
about is it addictive properties how
addictive it is how
how uh destructive or painful whatever
the uh
the withdrawal
processes
what kind of things are we looking out
for yeah those are certain kind of
questions we certainly have asked
because like uh something like cry
cocaine versus alcohol or heroin when it
comes to
withdrawal or physical dependence like
cocaine has a very limited sort of
withdrawal symptoms i mean it's hard to
see
same is true with methamphetamine but
with heroin you certainly can see a
withdrawal syndrome that's displeasing
that's unpleasant
but with alcohol that withdrawal uh can
actually kill you so heroin is
unpleasant and not lovely but with
alcohol withdrawal that's the one that's
the most dangerous i mean all of these
kind of questions we want to know um
answers to uh and and so when we think
about uh heroin or some other drugs and
you say like what kind of negative
effects negative effects we don't talk
about much in the society the main thing
that really concerns me about like
heroin use really is constipation so if
people uh are using uh heroin on a
regular basis and then they have a sort
of slowing of their gut motility
they're in they're likely to increase
constipation and that's not good i mean
for your general health but we never
talk about that in this society and
that's probably the most important thing
aside from the fact that people get
contaminated street drugs and that sort
of stuff and increase the likelihood of
maybe dying from some contaminant or
people who are inexperienced and they're
mixing heroin with other sedatives
that's not good but the constipation
is a huge one um and then other sort of
drugs negative effects
um like the amphetamines all of the
amphetamines they differ they disrupt
sleep food intake all of these things
are so critical for sustaining human
life
but we never talk about that because
it's not as sexy as this nonsense that
people write about like addiction
addiction has almost nothing to do with
the drugs themselves and i make that
comment because um the vast majority
abuser for users for any drug
never become addicted and so if the vast
majority of users don't become addicted
then you have to move beyond the drug
when you're talking about the phenomena
interest in this case addiction and and
so when we think about addiction it has
much more to do with our psychosocial
environment than the drug itself
but that's not sexy
so addiction is even the property of the
environment not a property um a result
of the environment it certainly can be
there are people who are
suffering from
co-occurring mental illness like
depression anxiety i mean that's within
the person of course and that increases
the likelihood for addiction so that
could that's um not so much the
environment but there are people who
for example they have chronic
unrealistic expectations heaped on them
and those people are more likely to have
some problems with drugs
there are people who are just immature
not
develop having developed responsibility
skills they are likely to have some
problems if they
engage in some of these behaviors there
are people who lost their jobs covert
factories went away a wide range of
things and those people used to have
standing in their community now they
have none um those people might be
susceptible to having a drug related
problem if they indulge
all of these kind of issues are far more
important than the drug itself
so they could seek escape in a
particular drug i mean there
there is a biochemical thing to each of
these drugs and some more some pull you
in harder than others when you need the
escape right when you're not doing well
in life
what evidence you have for that booster
i don't i because there is none there is
absolutely none i mean people say
stuff like that and um
that's the problem that's precisely the
problem see i'm operating from limited
personal evidence
well this is a problem though but we
have a scientific database yeah we don't
need personal evidence for this we have
in my book i try to go through some of
the science so people could unders
understand it's like
uh when you have a math problem you
don't want people saying well you know i
feel like this [ __ ] what you feel what
does the data say
you